toying with violence mishandling a
cinematic debut here's how things went
from ThunderCats hoe to Thundercats no
let's get down to brass tacks
controversial is the last word that
comes to mind when watching an episode
of Thundercats in fact the show's
creators were so dedicated to promoting
a positive message that they brought in
a qualified psychologist to analyze each
script and make sure the stories contain
the strong moral themes but that didn't
stop Thundercats from being unfairly
judged by the naysayers the most popular
kids cartoons of the 1980s were
routinely criticized by influential
protest groups who argued that these
shows were nothing more than violent toy
ads naturally Thundercats caught the ire
of some of these groups resulting in a
campaign to have it removed from
syndication along with shows such as
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and He-Man
according to the New York Times action
for children's television led the charge
in the war for the children's Souls the
group even took its protests to the
Federal Communications Commission
however its censorship campaign was
dismissed after the government agency
deemed the cartoon suitable for public
consumption provided that they didn't
advertise their own merchandise during
episodes similarly the series worried
Boston is at the BBC in the UK who
refused to air it unless specific Cuts
were made to the episodes
during the Golden Age of children's
cartoons millions of young viewers tuned
in to watch the shows and convince their
parents to buy all of the Italian
merchandise that accompanied them so you
can understand why Studios felt
compelled to make spin-off movies based
on some of the most popular series at
the time unfortunately films such as
Transformers the movie GoBots Battle of
the rock Lords and My Little Pony bombed
at the box office leading to the
cancellation of Thundercats hoe as a
theatrical release Thundercats hoe was
instead released as a TV movie before
being turned into five separate episodes
that ushered in season two the plot sees
the titular cat-like Heroes out to find
three more fellow felines who escaped
the destruction of the planet and ended
up on third Earth all the while adding
more context to the ThunderCats history
that being said turning movies into
succinct 20-minute TV episodes requires
cuts to be made often resulting in some
key story beats being removed in the end
the repurposed Thundercats hose story
confused viewers more than it should
have it turns out that adding a bunch of
random episodes to the beginning of the
second season without offering any real
explanation didn't improve the show's
continuity of course if the box office
performances of the aforementioned movie
spin-offs were anything to go by it's
possible that kids were simply turning
their attention to other cartoons
[Music]
caught off to a flying start with
Animation Studio Rank and bass
Productions creating 65 episodes for
season one alone green lighting's such a
large number of episodes was quite
standard in the 1980s basically having
such a large quantity of programming
allowed television networks to broadcast
popular series five days per week for a
span of 13 weeks in regard to 80s
animated shows bulking up on episodes
also gave the broadcasters plenty of
material for syndicated reruns for years
to come following the success of the
first season of Thundercats 65 episodes
were ordered by the telepictures
corporation for a follow-up but the days
of fresh episodes of Thundercats airing
every single day for weeks on end were
gone instead the network opted to
release the new batch across three 20
plus episode Seasons which aired between
1987 and 1989. Thundercats was no longer
viewed as a worthwhile long-term
investment at the same time it must be
said that any show that survives for 100
plus episodes must be chalked up as
success story in the grand scheme of
things was ThunderCats set up for the
sole purpose of selling toys absolutely
not however despite the series strong
moral Fabric and commitment to
entertaining storytelling the
merchandise was always going to
influence the series according to
Thundercats writer Kimberly Morris the
creators were often instructed to write
new characters into their stories at the
behest of the toy manufacturer ljn
however the creative team supposedly
relished the opportunity to give the toy
Concepts some interesting backstories
and were more than happy to oblige when
the sales started drying up in the late
1980s though the show's cancellation was
all but inevitable by the time
Thundercats fourth and final season
rolled around ljn had stopped producing
action figures to tie in with the series
therefore the decision to discontinue
the line before the fourth installment
aired suggests that the writing was on
the wall for the show heading into the
remaining episodes the story didn't end
on a sad note at least time has been
kind to Thundercats and its action
figure line according to Transformer
land ljn's figures vehicles and cards
have become desired Collectibles that
command a hefty price tag to this very
day let me show you what it's capable of
in the proper hands it's rare for any
popular 1980s IP to ever truly fade away
if the live-action adaptations of
Transformers and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles tell us anything it's that
Hollywood keeps them on Ice until the
iron is hot again Thundercats is no
different as it was reported Godzilla vs
con director Adam wingert would be
tackling a hybrid CGI and animation film
adaptation of the famous feline Warriors
discussing his plans with deadline
Wingard revealed he would be looking to
the original series for inspiration he
also revealed he was a major fan of the
franchise in general saying I was
writing my Thundercat screenplay through
my entire 10th grade year and I was
handwriting it the screenplay itself
ended up being
272 pages long however there have been
no major updates about wingard's
proposed film since 2021. this doesn't
mean the ThunderCats won't ever appear
again in different iterations as they've
been rebooted twice courtesy of 2011's
Thundercats and 2020's Thundercats Roar
it seems like Thundercats refuses to
abandon its place in the pop culture
Pantheon
[Music]